la cena è quasi pronta tutti a tavola
nego
credenti
sarà una vera
[Musica]
ma
siamo dove siamo finiti questa volta
il libro ci ha portato in un nuovo luogo
troveremo un'altra creatura qua vi
ricordate madre successo l'ultimo voto
se non lo avete visto andate poi a
vederlo e lasciate un mi piace mi
raccomando per portarci fortuna in
questa nuova avventura e nuova creatura
grazie mille tantissimi di voi hanno già
preso astori paura non abbiamo
l'alimentari vi sta piacendo tantissimo
grazie mille e ora pronti andiamo a
scoprire la prossima creatura
sembra che il libro indyk iniqua
facciamo di portare
c'è una casa che saprai allora sarà
dentro quella casa in questo caso la
casa cauto capa e sembra una casa
normale non come quella del lupo mannaro
vi ricordate eh sì proviamo a bussare
vediamo chi ci vive dentro mangia
[Applauso]
ma non si vede niente
che strano da questa finestra non si
vede niente anzi sembra proprio che sia
stata oscurata
guardate va beh vediamo se c'è un'altra
finestra c'è un altro pinetina
ma anche questa finestra e oscura si è
un po strano c'è una pianta e poi
oscurata almeno c'è una pianta già
sappiamo che forse qualcuno si viva ed
entrano speriamo che non ci viva la
creatura dentro lo scopriremo presto
proprio a gustare
e studiamo questo eccolo qua c'è chi
però in questa strana casa porta la
differenza prima latte intero non era
queste sono bianche ovvero chiesto
perché forse un indizio proviamo a
bussare magari si apre qualcuno e
possiamo fare queste domande chiederli
sta lottando perché le tende sono
bianchi invece che mere chiedere della
creatura per una volta che mi ricordo
quello che devo fare presto gustiamo
secondo voi che creatura troveremo fa
dentro pronti ora
dai
18 e nessuno qui
vedete sono bianchi e quindi ho pensato
che magari questo è posto giusto visto
che rivas alle tende sono nere
sembra una ragazza
salve buongiorno
disturbo
volevamo chiedere delle informazioni
prossimo amo delle creature ad esempio
possiamo
ancora molto
come molto presto farò le cinque di
pomeriggio
presto in che senso
era un po pallida il però non era una
creatura una ragazza normale ce li
possiamo stare tranquilli è solo che non
è molto ospitale questa ragazza
effettivamente proviamo a ributtarsi non
rispondi più utili andata guarda sembra
abbia lasciato la porta un po aperta ai
possiamo dare una sbirciatina per vedere
se c'è una creatura e tirava
controlliamo se c'è la creatura di
domani diciamo sbirciavo solo meno
cerchiamo di non farci scoprire s piano
piano ok
[Musica]
e qualcosa no ma il libro mi sta
portando qua quindi credo che stiamo nel
posto giusto
[Musica]
nel posto giusto ma abbiamo preso il
primo punto
[Musica]
arredamento particolare le maschere
c'è qualcuno dietro dovremo metterci
accertare alla creatura non conoscere
chi abita in questa casa concordo xvi
anche del
[Musica]
figlio volevano solo maneggiare la porta
era aperta quindi ci siamo permessi di
rientri nostra la mia
ok noi volevamo solo fra due domande non
ci tratteniamo ogni voleva
ok volevamo giusto dell'informazione
sulla creatura ma se proprio c è anche
una
delle
creazioni
forse è meglio non dirle niente proviamo
a conoscere la famiglia ea vedere la
casa e vediamo cosa succede
mio padre
mia madre
una madre
sembra il mio dormendo
infatti mi chiedevo
perché questo permette un angolo
riesce a suonare
[Musica]
molto piacere signora berlusca siria
stiamo parlando di passaggio grosse
pronunciamento con piacere anche per lei
ama te sei account ancora dormendo
per piacere
svegliata dormendo ancora non lo so
vista quando mi stai perdendo formale
grazie per la vostra ospitalità o credo
che a breve andremo via penso che si
devono e qui c'è mio padre
la famiglia quindi e rosa
stava lì il padre è un tormento sulla
sedia che ogni tanto mi addormento sulla
sedia ma di certo non in quella
posizione nessun membro di questa
famiglia mi sembra normale forse meglio
se ce ne andiamo via subito
[Musica]
mi metto in cui con noi ancora non avete
conosciuto lì
c'è anche un altro membro della famiglia
fortuna ma questo sarà sicuramente che
normale
madre mi sono di nuovo non già tributo
ri una strada o spento ti succede madre
mi
scusi ma cosa sta succedendo qui abbiamo
capace se si senta se non ho qui vicino
alla porta
ci accomodiamo
muto accendendo il fuoco
ho detto la cena la cera o ha detto cena
c'erano no no no no non importa la
tenera adesso non mi ricordo sono strade
di nuovo perché non importano una cena
che vuoi che sia una cena in fondo non
ha mai ucciso nessuno
certo sarete affamati sicura
noi siamo così sicuri rimaniamo a ce ne
sono se voi ci date le informazioni su
una creatura che stiamo cercando che
insieme si possa giusto così possiamo
fare
a meno
che la creatura
accomodatevi pure scomodiamo accomuniamo
certo sul controverso regli questo che
che cos'è
caldi
il karkadè nel 1800 detto
ok puzza di ferro zolfo ottimo
sapore delizioso
torniamo alle morti questo grazie stiamo
bene così a noi interessa solo sapere
l'informazione sulla creatura ma anche
ci dimentichiamo la lascerà ricordati
che dobbiamo prendere tutti i voti
altrimenti verranno trasformati delle
velature come ha detto valigie sì ma
dobbiamo anche mangiare prendiamo anche
le informazioni ma mangiamo ricordiamoci
di mangiare non so se un'idea
sapete cosa faccio devo preparare la
cena
per un robot sentite visto che stiamo
aspettando che vostra madre prepari la
cena possiamo iniziare a fargli le
domande sulla creatura adesso
allora semplicemente va dello iom
ospitarvi tutta la storia non
dobbiamo assolutamente trovare
una creatura
[Musica]
ci stanno guardando un modo così strano
vabbè comunque dobbiamo trovare queste
creature altrimenti se non prendiamo
tutti i punti
beh abbiamo una maledizione quindi se
non prendiamo tutti i punti
diventeremo noi una creatura noi
dobbiamo assolutamente trovare le
collezioni punti nel libro che turri
che ricordi forse quelle enormi falle
minuti stelle gp3
ma poi ma in realtà parlavamo di
creature sovrannaturali silvia fatto che
ci sono
creature soprannaturali le nostre
guarda meglio di nuovo l'ultima volta in
sai guarda bello trasformato in un lupo
mannaro sono beni dappertutto razzi
russi
mamma mia che schifo non mi ricordo
nemmeno se mangiato quando quella volta
che sono stato trasformato noi odiamo e
lupi mannari
si prendono anche il nostro cibo si
berlusca
gli ospiti sono affamati
ci siamo massignano
scusate
ma io non mi sono
presentato
mi sembrate intimo i
nominali
mi sembrate ma io sono con te
filiberto cosa stavate cercando e allora
praticamente una lunga storia comunque
noi stiamo cercando una creatura
sovrannaturale perché lì ma ho già detto
che la creatura equa quindi è un pò
strano che voi non avete mai visto
nessuna creatura qua fuori in giardino
in casa non lo so che non vi siete mai
accorti di niente non so qui in casa o
fuori in giardino ma memori particolari
avete mai visto
conte filiberto si è addormentato signor
fuoco siete aiutato no scusate
che è meglio non si preoccupi fosse
camera fini si dove potevo trovare
queste creature
creature come creature ecco come
creature come soprattutto raleigh molto
grandi
soprannaturale siamo noi
mio padre voleva dire siamo noi a mobili
mandato per usciva quello
che ho già detto che porta la dentiera
[Musica]
[Applauso]
ma insomma possibile che non avete mai
sentito un rumore raro
tipo possono fare
[Musica]
anche questo non l'avete vista
se si deve alla fine sta alla finestra e
oscurato anche quelle non si può anche
aprire sarà possibile perché è più non
c'è niente
la cena è quasi pronta tutti a tavano
niente ha commentato
perché è pronto
ma
dove sono i piatti le portate mangiavo
con le mani magre aiutare cani
iniziamo dagli ospiti grazie
vedrete chiede il piatto
non vedo l'ora o una fame io
sarei il primo ad essere seri che bello
che bello mi vedo
un fazzoletto che qualcosa per coprirmi
devono sporcarne nuova band la fame
mangia mangia che vorremmo
si mangia tanto quindi
state posate ci sono ancora su ricatti
pensa troppo che si mangia
questo vino sembra del 1800
deve essere un vino un prodotto
intimorito che bella casa che avete si
vede che siete proprio dei minori
questa carta la faccio tempo abitate qui
probabilmente
c55 mi ha
reso vi ho già detto che porta lamenti
era
guerre 500 cinquecento anni sono tanti
non ho infatti a 105 500
[Risate]
siete quasi appena arrivati freschi
freschi bruno ma
venite a me fare da dove venite dalla
transilvania
l'antico siamo venuti con quelle grandi
navi abbiamo attraversato l'oceano
ma invece voi ragazzi che fate
andate a scuola beh certo io sono già il
previsto diploma al quinto diploma
5 10 15 20 25 anni
come ma il nome nuovo
è un po rimbambito il mio fratellino
se viviamo noi ti prende il fumo è anche
a volte due diplomi all'anno
se un diploma all'anno 5 anni 5 di blog
e book russo
0 eccomi caro arrivo
ho impiegato un po di tempo ma vi
assicuro che il risultato
sognare una prova finalmente vedere
lippi
sarà una vera sorpresa
che bello non vedo l'ora
signora rus cassini mancano i piatti
servono i piatti per questa pietanza non
serve è qualcosa di originale ma cosa
c'è una vendetta majlis
rete dove vengono loro è usanza non
sarei piatti mi piace mi piace molto la
forza perché ho
pochissimo qualcosa che non sa di tiro
mai assaggiato
[Musica]
e successo no e mettono un po strano il
fratellino ma si sono accorte ce la
fanno sembrare collo prima
beh equilibrio
nella madra tradizione chi deve aprire
più ingrosso radiospia ruspi
succede ma
se succede
[Musica]
vabbè se io avrò solo si raffredda
mano nella
mano
[Musica]